is it true though that you learned a
special skill for the movie
oh yeah so um i'm in addition to being
like an astronaut i'm the medical
researcher on
on i'm a space doctor i'm a doctor i'm
really smart
um but they uh they got this doctor to
come
and there's a scene where i have to
perform stitches yeah and um
this guy came and you practice on like
this
prosthetic this like prosthetic piece of
skin that's like
um do you know you know those like
chicken cutlets that you put in your bra
yeah yeah yeah i throw them at people so
it's like that material
and it feels like very icky and there's
like an open
it like looks they make it look real
like probably
probably so that you really want to
stitch it tight so that you're not
seeing the like
gross like bloody did you learn how to
stitch someone up
uh no i mean i i like perform stitches
on a prosthetic
in the movie that's like a much smaller
prosthetic and it's also in an emergency
very
close to someone's skin so like yeah i
mean if you fall down and i've got
if i've got a needle on me i'm i feel
like i'm more qualified than you
yes you are so i i am basically a doctor
yes i
i am anna kendrick md dr kendrick
that's all it takes a nice ring